[Applause]
it is time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as i mom explain it
all and now it's official kylie jenner
has officially announced that she is
pregnant and is expecting a second child
with rapper travis scott she posted a
touching video making the announcement
on instagram yesterday
[Music]
you ready to go to mommy's doctor the
video shows her holding a positive
pregnancy test visiting the doctor with
travis and their daughter stormy and it
shows her revealing the news to her mom
kris jenner
oh
[Music]
the rumors had been swirling when
eagle-eyed fans noticed she did not post
any photos of herself for her birthday
which was apparently very out of the
ordinary no word on a due date yet but
congratulations to their family up next
let's talk about the latest in food
trends panera bread just added some new
menu options but the one everyone is
talking about is their new grilled
macaroni and cheese sandwich it's two
scoops of mac and cheese between two
pieces of white bread it also has some
parmesan crisps on it to give it a
little crunch the full sandwich cost ten
dollars half of one costs five dollars
and the full thing packs
860 calories now that's what i call
comfort food and finally a sweet video
message from steve the original host of
blue's clues is not only trending but it
is making anyone who watched him super
emotional
you remember how when we were younger we
used to
run around and hang out with blue and
find clues and talk to mr salt freak out
about the mail and do all the fun stuff
and then one day i was like oh hey guess
what big news i'm leaving he goes on to
explain that he went to college and he
learned a lot but he now realizes how
abruptly he left and that it may have
been confusing for a lot of kids he went
to college and he did a lot of growing
up we all did and that life has been
very hard but that we the viewers really
helped him and then he closed with this
i guess i just wanted to say
that after all these years
i never forgot you
ever
and i'm super glad we're still friends
thanks for listening
you look great by the way
whatever it is you're doing it's working
i'm not crying you're crying okay yes i
am steve never forgot about any of us
and we didn't forget you steve and now
you've had a mom splitting